hi guys this is Joe from geek out genom
we bring you the very first unboxing of
the new how we maintain direct from
Munich I'll be following this up with
more dairy hands-on articles so use this
as a guide to get a good feel or what to
expect in hallways latest phone so right
now I'm gonna take off the Box
not sure what color it is Oh looks nice
this looks like to be the new mocha
brown color and yes it is as you can
tell get the focus you know
it's tricky with all the refractions
okay mocha brown is actually a metallic
body and let's see what's in the items
in the box before we moving on to the
cam phone proper put the phone one side
are we design up here
and we see our standard stuff this looks
like to be a case a manual pin for your
SIM card slot earphones what's this
charging don't go any power flow oh USB
okay let's open another
yeah we have the carrying case but I
think case pretty standard how we nice
to include these in their phones manual
and
phone sorry and the pin your phone's
what we've seen from Huawei these days
pretty good
respectable
and it's USB see
pretty much all phones have USB see
these days this website
and we have teeny
charger
I'm from Singapore so these tend to be
very normal I like these charges small
form-factor easy to carry around good
for trips okay let me put this one side
here we go here's the new Halloween
meat ten let's
so much fingerprints oh what's this I
noticed it does have a
skinned pices already applied to the
phone itself and so I guess the only
thing left to do is to remove it from
the packing thing people gonna like this
not
this one
well beautiful
wing logo at the bottom here
no logo in the front
looking good
and
just look at the like camera
get some focus here
mmm looks like this there's some residue
here from the scream director but it's
the problem the branding is very
prominent and
they look to be very proud to show after
the attacks behind this
game pretty much that's it for now this
is the new Huawei mate 10
awesome
let's pull it up then let's see how it
goes
whoa
hmm opens of the EMU I
go for English United Kingdom
mmm insert sim card I don't have a SIM
card on hand cause I'm recording from my
own phone right now so let's skip to
this and see how it looks like
agreeing of his name I agree
green green oh
[Music]
let's give this one out
shredding cool you gotta accept it and
it's done that's fresh
mmm skip this one now we're gonna put in
Miami gnome editor let's quickly get to
tea
[Music]
open UI screen the
home screen and see how it looks like
girls at the top
okay I set the focus
focusing
still loading here
oops I realized and you get started Oh
looks pretty clean actually
doesn't like anything really special in
terms of
the look and feel
very fluid and wow
[Music]
this green
looking at the settings here right now
well there's so many options even screen
recording comes in default
4G oh yes this is a new feature with the
new mobile phones 4G in both SIM cards
if you are looking those him right now
for most SIM cards the issue is that
only one can be using 4G but right now
obvious is that we can use two at the
same time
sure if this will make into the final
version but this is why I'm seeing right
now let's check it out mmm screenshot
while we share
King go to applications Oh
swift key is default my favorite
my favorite keyboard me so there we have
it this is the new while we
meet 10